oh we never finished scientists
it's okay
hello everybody
am i
i just got your name oh there we go
what's up sword
what's up dj spook jaden blaze
what i can't say some of these things
and now it's too fast what's up
everybody
yeah how's it going
what is up what is up guys and gals this
is
the big hawkeye episode
jeff thank you so much for that super
chat jeff aquino aquino
this is the big one so yes let's go
um in fact i just got off the phone
with the real rejects and they met kevin
feige
and even kevin feige said episode five's
a big one
that's so exciting
so
yeah
guys
i'm not going to talk about knowing
i i'm not spoiling anything for nowhere
very sorry to disappoint but uh
i actually can't say anything about it
until
the movie actually comes out
oh okay just testing the sound i
actually can't say anything because uh
you know you sign stuff with sony
and uh if i did that
sonny would never invite me back to
anything ever again so i'm not uh
i'm not gonna say anything about
spider-man knowing home i can't reveal
anything and i've heard it all blink
three times blah blah blah blah
you know
do three spider symbols if they're in it
you know don't blink if they're in it i
i've heard it all at this point right
now i know uh i know what's also gonna
happen
uh but
uh yes for those asking i am
oh thank you so much for that super chat
appreciate it creep uh do the creeper
thank you i like that uh profile pic too
what are this called
um i didn't see it crawlers no uh oh
creepers creepers yeah the
creep that's his that's his name
obviously
thank you for the super jack um let me
pull up some stuff here so i don't miss
any um
so i don't miss anything first of all
memberships are live now
and i have some
people to thank for signing up pb and
jen thank you for becoming a member
sebastian bimbinec
lethal nate thank you very much
the one sock nugget thank you very much
moises sombrana kellen brown thank you
thank you both tattoo akinen thank you
jst martin 91 thank you your boy brandon
and we did figure out it it is brandon
who i talked to
thank you
quinn's harmony
thank you very much and mr anderson of
course the best mod thank you thank you
thank you thank you very much
go to supers
and make sure i don't miss any of them
just so
boom
so creep out thing for the super chat
you're amazing for being here all right
i'm going to put these over here to make
sure i don't miss any oh there's one
right there
hey creepers become a member thank you
so much we super appreciate that
thank you thank you thank you thank you
welcome to the cosmic fam howdy partners
thanks for the superhero i can't wait
for no way home releasing tomorrow i
can't wait for you to see it uh
i loved it so much
it's awesome
everybody welcome back ally cat
we're just calling ali i guess her
handle on instagram is alicat official
the whole thing you can follow her on
instagram and uh
yeah she runs marvel minute news be sure
to go follow that channel mr anderson
will plug it down below
please shout out to mr anderson
always
coming in with mod did you hear that the
door was that the door something oh
hello hello we're experiencing a snow
storm right now
allie loves the cold
check this out this is the front
look at the whole door
oh my gosh look at the bottom
droop parking ball thank you for that
super chat howdy partners hey welcome to
the cosmic fam thank you so much for
becoming a member super super appreciate
that hi austin
did i miss out or just someone said hi
no hello
hi
uh drew thank you for that super chat i
super appreciate that drove i'm so i'm
so sorry if i don't pronounce names
right
spiderman okay i see a lot of questions
about spiders spiderman no way home i am
not spoiling anything that would be so
unfair to so many people um but the
premiere was amazing i met a lot of
awesome people
but most importantly the movie was
way more
than i expected it to be it wasn't
it was different like i said in my
review i i kind of thought it was going
to be one thing and it it was it was
different than i thought it was going to
be
and i'm really really glad it was
different than i thought it was going to
be because it it blew me away you're
going to love it you're going to love it
i don't think anyone's walking away from
this movie going like that movie sucked
i just don't i don't think that could
happen did i miss a member
howdy partners and creep okay cool
just making sure awesome but but it was
i mean it was
it was fantastic the movie was fantastic
it really really really was
making sure you don't for miss any super
chats here who's excited for hawkeye
we're not talking about hawkeye you
think
this is a hawkeye live discussion or
something
drop thank you so much big fan love
seeing you and that [ __ ] dude yes it was
so cool seeing him it was so cool seeing
him and we sat right next to each other
during the movie and we like we were
probably like this far apart and like
every now and then i'd just be like
and every now and then he turned to me
like
and they've like and we both like we're
like yelling like standing up we're
getting up and yeah it was awesome it
was really really cool
really really really cool um so thanks
for the super shot drove and uh
yeah i mean it was great to meet him
finally great to meet him finally uh
thank you for the super ishmael montoya
um i don't know what oh you means
oh slash ooh do you know what that means
hey warren
oh oh slot over under 50 oh over under
50 kingman shows up tonight
i've been told this is the episode that
something big i've actually been told
that it's gonna break the internet
and that's from somebody who i
you didn't tell me that
i did say technically she did say that
on her channel technically she didn't
say that on channel but i've been told
by like people who who know who have
seen it that
that this will break the internet and
even feige last night said that episode
five's the big one
i'm excited so i want to say over 50
kingpin i'm thinking maybe daredevil
shows up
to break the internet
so
i
that's just my thought ritwik
joe
i know who you are obviously we interact
all the time i don't know how to
pronounce your name but welcome to the
cosmic fam i feel like you've been a
part of the fan for a while though
because we we interact a lot i believe
we talk on uh on twitter too in dm so
welcome welcome welcome thank you so
much jeff another super chat we're going
to see fist today i i think so i
but let's let's ask honestly let's ask
no it's last year
because the last time you said kingpin
he showed up the last two times i've
been correct so i'm really nervous to
say anything about this time so
say it anyways no i don't know i really
don't
lame whatever happens is what's gonna
happen whatever happens is what's gonna
happen wow
you heard that here first people
i don't know because there's so many
things going around
there is um creep uh my favorite marvel
series i think has to be loki
um i think it goes logo
juan division
and we'll see how hawkeye ends before i
can before you i think what if his last
i think hawkeye is going to be up there
hawkeye is starting to get up there i
think right now i put it over falcon the
winter soldier and it's not that i don't
like falcon 1 soldier i did like it um
but hawkeye is starting to really bring
some really cool aspects into it
um
yeah uh please don't put spoilers in the
chat people um and if it helps the chat
feel
any better um
a lot of
a lot of people have been commenting
things that aren't real
like i've seen some comments that are
just like oh yeah
like the spider-man don't show up they
do show up only one shows up but then he
dies and bloat like there's a lot of
like you know this person shows all this
stuff it's like there's so much stupid
stuff posted out there it's really funny
to me actually now that i know exactly
you know
everything that's going on so
yeah i haven't seen anything
on my stuff surprisingly
it just happens oh that's so nice of you
thank you and you
oh wait do i not have
do i not have oh no
oh this is why it always makes me do
this
oh and i pulled it over here
well guess what
that gets you well i think mr anderson's
already on it
i felt like don't need somebody too i
felt like panning somebody and now i get
to boom
goodbye cool
uh tinas nelson what is up back uh
multiverse of madness trailer like today
uh
[Music]
i didn't see it did you see it
well let's not talk about it because
spoilers in the chat we don't want
spoilers on the chat
talking about videos is is okay because
i can i can pre-warn people
um right
but i i can't really pre-warn random
people to come in the chats at random
time and uh i don't want to give give uh
spoilers
i don't think that's fair um
but i'll have to take a look at that
i'll take a look i've been i like been
in the airport since the morning
you know i slept in because we worked
all night went to the premiere worked
all night
slept in woke up went to the
uh
airport flight was delayed got here
slept for like
20 minutes we all we went to eat and
then here we are
so i haven't really uh i haven't tuned
in today to anything because i already
you know i put out my review and that's
kind of what i was doing
and then we had a blizzard that was that
was something what time is it oh
what time does it come out each week 12
15. right on the dot
right on the dollar we're gonna test her
today
we're gonna test her today y'all i
really wish i was in the movie i i wish
uh
my backpack is in the movie flash
thompson wears the same backpack that i
that i have it's a gucci backpack and i
posted it on uh
on instagram
and uh
it was it was just funny it was funny
he's like walking in school i was like i
saw the strap i was like that's my
backpack and you like turned around i'm
like that's my backpack
like i literally wore it on the plane
and everything so
going to
wear my spiderman costume on the 16th
moises some brown and moises is a member
of the channel thank you very much for
the super chat as well
yes please wear your costume and uh tag
me on like twitter and stuff
please please please
christmas please
auggie stachelberg i see that it popped
up but i don't see there it is what do
you think is gonna break internet you
know we were talking about this
um
i ha here are my thoughts it's it's
it's it's fisk right it's kingpin wilson
fest kingpin
played by d'onofrio
right
so he's back right he played him in the
netflix series and now he's back or it's
kingpin and
daredevil matt murdock now here's a
thought i had
what if it's black widow what if black
widow's alive they did say
she was that's a good question right
they did say um
scarlett johansson was gonna return
for to work at marvel but they they they
made it seem like it was going to be in
like a director yeah like in the
director part and uh
so probably not alive but i think that
would just absolutely just go crazy um
what is that what is that maybe
um so auggie i think
i think i think that's
i think that's
what i think it's i think no matter what
we get kingpin
right
and then
and and i shouldn't say and then and
maybe
maybe daredevil
kevin feige mentioned daredevil
before
saying that he's going to be in some
projects
mentioned
didn't mention what projects though and
then he also mentioned again
how
it's going to break the internet right
hey marina how's it going that's so cute
i love it i love it thanks for the super
chat welcome welcome welcome marina has
been a supporter of the fan or
supportive fan um supportive of the
channel
for a while and uh she always donates
and she's super sweet thank you marina
thank you thank you very much for
helping support the channel she could be
back but as a scroll ritwick that's a
good point
that's a good point
like a fate like yeah someone that's
like a scroll pretending to be here or
you know there's there's the far-fetched
theories out there that are like oh the
black widow that died was a scroll you
know like
i don't i don't have to say spoilers for
her dying and in-game right we've all
we've all seen him get in games
yeah
if you haven't why are you here
that poor farmer
the poor
talking about that
poor for
um
oh vic
that's a good question probably ego
yeah yeah probably ego mr anderson can
we drop some links for
miss ali's channel
please in the chat just do that every
every now and then
and uh i'm really sure
or i'm pretty sure i shouldn't say like
i'm really sure i'm pretty sure that uh
it's kingpin that we're getting tonight
oh we got some super chat so just trying
to check something real quick
okay
let's address these because we always
gotta get the super chats
infinity shades hey always coming back
every week and i super appreciate that
and it's great to see you again i hope
you're excited for today's episode
moises thanks for the super chat super
supportive love it uh marvel universe
should make marvel zombies movie you
should make dc
should make
movie marvel vs dc movie i
agree with you i'm just gonna say it i
agree with you
creepo you're in a hostel okay can't
watch vitamin home and every time i open
my phone it's gonna be split yeah it's
uh that's gonna be rough um
i really would
try to avoid things because i think
variety like did it again
right like variety spoiled the post
credit scene of eternals
and i heard they spoiled
something about no way home so don't go
to variety don't follow anyone from
variety unfollow them because apparently
they're just douchebags
so yeah i it just kind of blows my mind
away that's such a big outlet is uh
is doing that i'm scoot forward a little
bit more if you want to because my back
hurts i need to reach my mouse
um so
watch out for a variety
um harrison klim
turn off the chat people are spoiling
truth facts uh
i don't want to turn off the chat
because
i don't want to i want to be able to
talk to you all
but be careful with the chat guys don't
please don't put spoilers in the chat
and um
i haven't i actually haven't really seen
much the ones that i have seen are are
fake
[Music]
and mr anderson's like
mr anderson seems to be on it
um i haven't really seen many spoilers
in the chat
um but i will tell you this i will tell
everybody this
me being who i am meaning the guy that
digs in and finds the spoilers and talks
to the people in the industry and
everything like that
um
i probably only knew about
10 minutes
of the movie going into it
wow like it's two and a half hour long
movie and i thought i knew a lot
but in total what i knew was only about
ten minutes of a movie which is really
weird cause i would say like oh yeah i
know the whole movie and like i i know
like bits and pieces that happen in
between but like the tiny tiny little
details
of what happens is is
we don't know
and that's really cool and the fight
scenes are fantastic by the way tom
holland did an amazing job and the way
that he
fights
the villains like
his one-on-one hand-to-hand combat which
i think he talked about he was doing
more of it and he did that was really
really cool and there's some parts in
there where you're just like oh
and it's super super cool
not today thanks for super chat from
india going to watch it tomorrow that's
awesome i really really hope you you
enjoy it i feel like you
i feel like everybody will i i feel like
that it's just i don't see how people
can't enjoy the movie i just i just
really don't so i mean
yeah
the fist does gonna show up in episode
five marvel studios that's the official
marvel studios telling us
let's uh let's get this set
for for disney but i want to hear your
gift i want to hear your all's
predictions what what do you all think
this really big
thing is huh
what do y'all think you're watching 11
hours that's awesome wait
it's tuesday night yeah
i'm not watching it again
until thursday
yeah
you too
not again the first time
yeah um
guys if you
if you don't want spoilers for no way
home
you should really
avoid the internet until you watch it
that's literally the best advice i could
give you
like i promise you i won't spoil it i
won't spoil it in like a thumbnail or
title or anything like that i'm i'm not
gonna be that guy i'm not gonna be that
guy
but
i know people are gonna be that guy it's
okay it's amazing
it's late and you have a nerd
what time are we leaving tomorrow
i'm done no thank you moises not too
early i appreciate that a lot he
subscribed to both of us oh awesome and
he's a member of my channel thank you
thank you thank you super appreciate
that
i feel like too what are you doing
you're making me
stop because it's gonna come back to me
simps
get
timed
out
turned on the volume of the super chat i
don't
actually know how to do that
oh you know what i can do though why
doesn't it go through the mic
what do you mean
it makes a lot of noise through some
sort of speed yeah speakers
it does go through the mic that's how
they're hearing it
so
because otherwise we'd have to go
through headphones
no we both want to be we don't need to
hear anything really you know so
um brandon super chatted thank you so
much that super chat do i think we'll
ever get john berthold
punisher in the mcu um
so like here's the deal um
i don't want people to like really start
to think
like
kevin feige mentioned that like you know
if if daredevil does come to mcu yes he
will be played by
charlie cox like
i don't want people to start thinking
that that's like the norm for all the
netflix people because
like i just i don't think that's how
it's going to be
um
i just i just really don't think that's
how it's going to be so
so don't get
that in your head
but the answer to your question is i
hope he is
um
because i think it was perfect as the
punisher um
but i'm not expecting it the only people
that i'm expecting are
daredevil and kingpin like to be frank
those are the only two like returning
actors from
the
netflix series
not really i guess reprise their
characters
not roles because they're gonna they're
not gonna be the same characters right
so
yeah
infinity seeds what if we sent for you
cosmic chat that's funny uh that's
allowed simps for me are allowed
just not for you
dad one of my fans
on a million subs creep um
i'm gonna do the
that's the tobey maguire dance
live
for 10 min i don't know
something like that um i'm gonna
do i'll do a live stream or something
and we'll celebrate together and uh
we'll buy him a cake don't worry
a cake cookie cake a cookie cake it'll
say one million subs so you're telling
me in four minutes this is coming out
yes
what if it's already out it's not yet
it's not yet
wait four minutes john walker could show
up i don't think that would break the
internet austin simpson for both y'all
thank you thank you thank you
what about the batman i love
the batman i haven't seen the movie yet
but i'm really really
really
really looking forward to it like really
looking forward to it um
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so
did i miss
[Music]
yeah let me just make sure i don't miss
any super chats
more cosmic chat on your
on my cake on your cake one million subs
cosmic chad what's the tag come from
it's just like a term
oh i didn't know that
i think i got them all i think i got all
the super chats and if i missed any i do
apologize i'm going through the list
right now
and i believe
i got them all
oh
okay
my screen went blank for a second
just like
blacked out
i just want to watch a hunger
no yes no
sit through this i see it
troy james thank you for the super chat
i'm trying to pull it up now
what trick arrows do you want to see
well i i i definitely think there's
going to be
in this episode or the next a boomerang
shot because they mentioned it in the
last one in hawkeyes like why would i
want that that to me seems like some
pretty big foreshadowing of um what's to
come what breaks the internet it's gonna
like save his life somehow right it's
like a boomerang arrow this is green
drinking the internet
i get points for that one
so we have a scale any time ally makes a
funny joke i give her points
and anytime she makes a bad joke i to
duck points
it's true facts it's true it's fun let
me tell you guys i'm like negative
points so
it's true bye creepa thanks for becoming
a member and thanks for the super chat
super appreciate it love back to india
see ya
one more minute according to miss ali
here
i think you're pretty close to to ride
on that no i think i'm 100 accurate on
every single time it's at 12 15.
hey
thanks moises yes thank you so much
please sub marvel minute news
it's ali's channel
um it's quick news whereas i'm gonna
give you that super in depth here's what
i think about everything news whereas
she's just gonna go hey guess what this
was said today bye thank you sharya
oh mr anderson with the emotes what
up
all right
12 49
12 15. and it's out
look at that that's my only prediction
for the men nope
that's my
breaking the internet all right i'm
going to google putting a timer up stop
watch mr anderson get ready because
we're about to do it
ronan the title of the episode is ronin
and it's 45 minutes okay and here we go
in three
two
one
and here it is hold on let me match up
the times
okay now we're on one second okay
two three i don't hear it either
they really do
that's why
maybe not
okay
wow that's gorgeous where are we at i
don't know 2018 whoa
guys i'm actually so excited
oh
who are these people
oh it's another black widow and elena
where are they
oh
anna
well that was fast
we jumped right into it
she missed
[Music]
no that gets me shivers
oh
2018
so yeah what happened in 2019
oh they're freeing the oh they're
freeing them they're freeing the black
widows from their
troy welcome to the cosmic fam thank you
so much for becoming a member
ha
20 really 20 grand for a rug
no that was wrong
killing for money
okay
they've helped a lot
swa welcome to the cosmic fam
thank you for becoming a member
so they're freeing black widows
oh
so they're
they're freeing black widows
yelena was freeing black widows
and they just mentioned then you'll go
live with natasha once you're done
it's 2018 so
she's not dead yet
what the oh no
she was dusted
and she just came back
wow
no
wow
whoa
yo linda was blipped
five years later because the blip was
five years so now
what
imagine
jeez
i need to find natasha
natasha's dead
dang well okay that was just the opening
and that was already pretty intense okay
uh
yeah
gonna open a g fuel oh no
okay we're good
do you want some do you feel i got stuff
on my mind you do have stuff on your
lips
i do have a straw
i shall use this oh do you want to use
this jar you want me to oh gosh
you know we could both use this
okay i don't care about your lipstick
all right here we go
i cannot lose okay it doesn't
the freak
now you're giving us the previously
they just kind of started off with a pop
jack ducane is the ceo
well you killed her father so
what would you expect
a black widow assassin
i'm not gonna do it
we're just recapping right now everybody
all right where are we at in the city
haha
back at the house
so all right she's just gonna rock and
be like jack what are you doing like
because i
and can he why is everybody gonna cry
because clint's her hero and he told her
to leave
kicked her out and
jack would be so disappointed
right
he's like what the hell bro
so kate's just talking to her mom she's
all roughed up she went home after
hawkeye was like yo get out
oh her mom's taking care of her
it's a good sight to see
even though she's evil
oh
sad
but you are kate you are a superhero
hmm
talk about jack
talk about something tell me something
i like her
even as an actor like i really like the
actress but like
even as what i believe to be a villain
i still like her
but you can and you will
they said a bad word and disney plus how
are they someone else
she said it do you ever worry about me
not finding my path
you know exactly who you are
which means you are
which means you are definitely about to
go back to hawkeye
guys if you post spoilers and some of
your spoilers are not spoilers i promise
you
you're making stuff
up you'll be banned
sloan limited
look she knows
call kingpin
kingpin there do something oh
oh that's that's maya
oh
she's messed up
oh cozzy
does he love her
is he in love with her
you don't have to pretend it doesn't
hurt with me
there was someone else tonight a woman
well trained
no i don't think they know who she was
her name is yelena belova
it's all bigger than i thought
interesting
when i'm so close she just wants ronin
to die because he killed her dad
i'm pretty sure he's in love with her
i'll help you capture ronin and kill him
but after that done
don't die
wait yeah this is her place after the
fire right
now there's still water yeah
she she hasn't been back to her place
after the fire
apparently not i guess not huh
that's yolanda
i really like her a lot
russian yeah
i know what a box mac and cheese tastes
like no it's delicious
drew backs girl
i'm one person
i did not try to kill you
i like florence pew a lot
currently
i don't have any weapons on me okay i
don't have any weapons in my hands
i mean your black widow
going to have dinner with the enemy
she made some really good macaroni
[Music]
i wanted to kill you already would have
oh come on i just want answers
hello hakeem hawkeye pocky hello hockey
hello hockey boy
grills
oh my gosh yeah come up that's so funny
i like girls i'm glad i'm glad they
brought him back
his character is nothing like he's
carried into comics but
i go
i can put hot sauce on it hot sauce and
macaroni
it's a lot of hot sauce
right
obviously there are reasons it's my
first time in new york
the empire state building
the new and improved statue of liberty
so is
after spider-man no way home statue of
liberty with the shield
i love american christmases
pb and jen i love her too
the super power rangers
sad
i mean i've had deer jerky and that's
like the best thing ever really yeah i
don't think i've ever had deer
the music's getting weird
it's getting
i thought i heard it getting weird like
i don't think
sometimes you're funny she's like so
confused
you keep saying my whole name just to
point out that you know it
oh my gosh
she's a black widow they know everything
i know
no prepare to kill him
wow looks like she might know what
happened
she's so straight up
kate thinks she could have killed elena
that one is the funniest
interesting
[Music]
wow dang
very precious
[Laughter]
this is intense
oh i just want to know what yelena
actually knows about what happened
three days two days four days
[Laughter]
about a week
it would not be difficult
yeah okay tell me yes someone hired you
to kill him
why it was val and why
oh
why don't you talk to him yolitta
oh you want to just ask k where he is
[Laughter]
thank you for the girls night
a mac and cheese
in a pan
hey it's a girls night
oh
do not get in my way
she could kill them both super quickly
so cool but i'm also curious how it
doesn't rip her arm off
but i think she put she puts it on her
belt i think yeah
oh look i was lucky
hmm that guy's gonna stay in a hotel for
christmas
pizza dog
new outfits for you and kate please be
please tell me it's comic accurate hot
guy
uh guys i talked to rpk i i don't think
uh
i don't think he is sony marvel
there
no
he is being framed
come on jack's not the bad guy she is
battle of new york memorial the avengers
thing on this site 2012 during the
battle of new york
the avengers first assembled steve
rogers tony stark thor odinson bruce
banner natasha romanov clint barton dang
no one recognizes him
right
oh
he's talking to natasha
hmm
dang
if yolanda kills him mama would be
pissed
right
dang
what
so sorry for what i'm about to do
wow
wow what is hawkeye about to do what's
about to go down
wonder if he knows that elena's her
sister
it's her dad all of her trophies
we're more than halfway done like what
the heck getting stuff
yeah why is he sorry
why yeah i know i mean
are you gonna take your kitty bow
it's all pretty crazy
[Laughter]
she's calling clint
over and over and over and over and over
oh no the mailbox is full
can't accept any more messages she
okay trust a bro what is happening track
suit mafia
all right what's about to happen
all right what's gonna happen
pull them out of your pocket
that's gonna happen
okay
there's a note in the arrow
alone
but we are not mine okay
start doing stuff
i know right
oh i'm so nervous
who's he calling
we need to talk
maya is
relentless
she has the watch she looked into our
family
someone's hired a black widow
we've been so careful
it's never far enough dang
you're a mockingbird just tell me now
before the big guy gets involved
i'm still nervous i don't know
it's gonna be like a post credit or
something
he called the second part
say i love you
um
[Music]
yay
i love how it says barton and then laura
but she's laura barton
okay there's maya
used cars fat man and they just said big
guy i mean just reveal the kingpin
already right
you are not alone maya
oh you are so not alone
you know what sucks though she's deaf
she doesn't have calms in her ear
okay so
ronan or hawkeye is taking out everybody
we can see himself
suspenseful music playing
are you a dream
y'all are not oh
y'all are not hidden at all like at all
what is happening why are they like
oh my gosh
just shot himself or
and she's deaf and she can't hear
anything gosh
which means it's the perfect time to
bring a daredevil
don't shoot all those used cars
oh this might be a spoiler part guys so
be aware of that but here's hawkeye as
ronin
oh with the sword
is it hawkeye
is it hawkeye
yeah it's gotta be is it hawkeye i don't
know but it seems like she just she just
took the sword from him
is it hawkeye and is she gonna find out
that it's hawkeye
i find it really i was gonna say i find
it really hard to believe that maya is
could be stronger than hakka
she does have the
um
i don't know whether titanium i don't
know what's made of titanium leg her
prosthetic leg whatever it's made out of
vibranium
whoa that was cool
take off who is it that doesn't look
like hawkeye his eye
were those hot guys eyes
we'll find out right now
it is hot guy i knew it
i'm so good at this
poof
dang
and dyke we're the same
you're a monster
we're weapons
could be manipulated
somebody tell me something come on
nothing's breaking the internet yet
no it's not
i was here that night
tipped off by informant
works for your boss
your boss
you're a lion
she is so unhappy
oh did kate bishop just show up
she did
he's gone
tell me
all right she's gonna go to kingpin and
she's gonna be like what the hell bro
okay who is this is it
it's quasi because that's kazzy's car
i just
why weren't you at the meeting that
night
you were in town
you were his number two her dad
the night my father was murdered
cause he's in on it
don't kill him
don't kill him
she's so angry
i mean she just wants revenge for
whoever killed her dad
okay we're running out of time
there's literally eight minutes left
it's it's time
um
it's natasha's sister
you're elaine oh he knows
dang
nothing's happened yet
but i mean we should have predicted it
was going to be at the very end right i
mean
yeah they just want to lead us on
what happens now
oh they kind of held hands right there
through there
oh okay okay here's the lady
who's she meeting
who's that's
that's the elena
and she's following her
well you know you know how to dress huh
this penthouse has to be kingpin's
penthouse there's no way it's not look
at this thing
does it have a bigger than average door
oh
is you only gonna break into or shoot
him in the face or
come on
okay bishop i found out who hired me
eleanor bishop
thought you deserve to know what
to kill him
who's that with my mom
that's kingpin
that's wilson fisk
yeah
there he is
[Music]
literally the last second of the
freaking thing
well dang
oh no the internet's not really broken
but okay
it's lagrange i mean i guess they gave a
lot yeah right they gave a lot of
information in the last little bit
well that's the guy okay wait where's
the cast does it say who it is by any
chance
the internet was broken by lucky the
pizza dog
he did dance
the hell's a cast
great music choice i love the grinch
okay
well at this point i don't think
anyone's surprised
there you have it um
watch for the cast
hold on we're gonna have to
nope didn't work
what's going on
oh no wait did you pass it
[Music]
you love that they use the grinch song
right after the reveal yeah
can you hear us yeah yeah yeah yeah i i
can hear you okay we can hear you
i can see it can you see us
yeah you're so pretty hold on
okay hold on hold on cast
kingpin vincent d'onofrio
it's literally listed in the cast
there you go problem solved
solving
okay isaac h yes i agree and thank you
for that super chat episode eight
or six i'm sorry it was gonna be nuts
vinnie d in the house vinnie vinnie
[Music]
kingpin vincent
is not for you and they just straight up
went for kingpin they didn't like mess
with the whole fist thing there's like
they were just like
worried about
kingpin
they are pretty loud okay well i shall
turn them in the down position in the
down position finally
finally thank you jake i appreciate it
i'm not sure people can hear you talk
for me hello people you were probably
pretty loud too dude i turned hello
everybody
thank you jake
oh i gotta put it pretty loud i gotta
put obviously i have to show you that's
what i'm i can see the tv i can see the
tv okay hold on thank you jake i
appreciate it i'm not sure yeah still no
press post credit scene t you're right
about that
but we did get the real legitimate
you know
the first
um
netflix character
to be recasted in the
marvel cinematic universe
the show keeps getting better and better
but most importantly free jack yes
bradley thanks for the super chat can we
talk about how i was totally right
there's just no way jack's the back i
mean that's obviously eleanor right she
met with kingpin
i mean
she brings up a pretty obviously good
point here says it implies the valentina
and fisk are working together right
so there's obviously something going on
there there's something pretty big
coming from this i don't unders
yeah that's that's um
we only have one more episode
we have one episode which and this is
going to go into the echo episode but
like
they have a lot to
wrap
up
like a lot more i think it's a super
chat i'm going to say no way home
uh i
i loved that movie i loved it two wins
and uh thank you for the super chat
marvel's doing good with the reveals on
the fifth episode yeah right
vinnie d is back oof
love it
love it love it love it it's so cool
that they're doing that you know kevin
feigerty came out and talked about
daredevil which
leads me to believe that he's going to
be coming pretty soon i mean i think the
echo series he's he's guaranteed to be
in there it just makes sense
and then they're going to fall in love
and he's blind and she's deaf
yeah right
i mean that's what happens in the comics
right
it's funny because in the comics she
falls in love with um
matt murdock not knowing he's not
knowing that he's daredevil yeah right
and then she finds out and then she
fights them right blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah so the
whole thing yeah but they kind of did
that whole twist here from that same
kind of comic story line where she finds
out kingpin's kind of a bad guy
which is the exact same comic storyline
you're kind of figuring out or talk
about with daredevil is what happens
there she does all the stuff kingpin
tells her to do because she's kind of
had this twisted manipulation happening
to her right that's kind of what ronan
just kind of unraveled with her where
she's asking quasi where were you that
night and so that that that's kind of
being pulled away it's the same thing
yeah it's it's going to be
kingpin
killed her dad right it was kingpin that
killed her the whole time yeah it's just
you know so and ha and hawkeye slash
ryan's gonna explain i was just killing
the big guy like right and i was told
this was a big guy i was told your
father was a big guy
ismail montoya thank you for the super
chat does king ping showing connect with
no way home i'm not going to answer that
i'm not going to say yes i'm not going
to say no i'm just going to let you guys
go into no way home blind
i've prepared you for it
blind
what's the answer ally you answer the
question
she's trying to get points is what she's
we've already explained to everyone
about did you explain everybody the
point system except my last joke was
really funny couldn't tell you what it
was because i can't remember but king
jay since kingpin is back daredevil
definitely has to be in no home again
i'm not answering these questions but i
will say i definitely think daredevil
and the mcu is a guarantee at this point
because dinafrio is back
right and we've been here in the same
room as we've been right they've been
going hand in hand with each other so
right and the echo series and the
importance of daredevil and all of that
from the comics
right and
and and kevin feige said it you know in
the in his interview right so yeah
that's the question i have here is
kingpin native to the mcu or pulled from
the multiverse the understanding that i
have and warren can can clarify if it's
otherwise maybe it's that these
characters have been recast yeah but
they're not picking up their roles from
the netflix series like it's not that
story so they took these characters
because of how much people love them
and they brought them to the mcu to
start over
in new stories yeah i think it's going
to be just completely different stories
um yeah
completely different
stories
whole new go at it because the
characters beloved
yeah i mean
same actor
same actors we're gonna just we're just
gonna go ahead and say charlie's
confirmed for returning at some point
um and
i i would stop it there guys i i
wouldn't expect everybody else i
wouldn't expect john to come back as per
punisher you know and right you know
luke gage all of them
christina sanford thank you for that
super chat what did i think of yolin in
this episode actually i loved her oh
much fun i i loved her
i'm glad i didn't kill you that's the
funniest thing you've said so far kate
cape is a big
her accent has gotten thicker though
yeah but i like
marvin
what marvel and their accents are just
so inconsistent so it's like back and
forth right it's really weird
call me because
i'm liking you
[Laughter]
oh man i'm just
i
how are they going to wrap it all up
well that's the big thing is it seems
like it's leading into maybe some
information about what valentina is
doing which is the purpose for sending
elena in there and now we know that
she's kind of connected to king ben and
all these different stories so
i don't i don't know i don't know how
they wrap it up
but it does seem like there's more
coming
it's
well here's the real question and you
could both answer it what do you want to
see in the next episode
i don't know because it's it's again
it's like
i feel like there's a million stories
going on
right you have so much story with
hawkeye and his wife who is clearly
somebody we were absolutely getting the
watch we went so far away blah blah blah
watch storyline the watch isn't cleared
up oh yeah i mean yeah alex like the
watch
yeah and then you have all this yolena
stuff the fisk stuff there's a lot of
stuff happening on kate
mom
the rodent thing um maya's thing there's
so much like
they're just gonna have to they're
literally just gonna have to start from
the beginning is the thing is they're
gonna this episode was a lot of fun but
it didn't it didn't really build on the
story a whole lot more they just kind of
they're gonna write it out go from the
beginning next episode like literally
just be like
okay
let's go i gotta go talk to them right
now
kate says i screw i'm going to see my
mom you know like
yo linda talks to hawkeye and it's like
tell me the truth and then they just
they just yeah that's obviously gonna
happen right right but they need to do
it soon is what i'm saying it can't they
can't do like 20 minutes of like talking
like they have to go the story has to
start
right king j i think super chat i think
kingpin will kill hawkeye
really hope not
i think he's gonna live i just don't see
how you have like a christmassy type of
disney plus right disney plus show
and it ends with him dying
what are the fear of time
i just really want to see maybe hawkeye
even kind of banding together the young
avengers which he can't do if he's dead
yeah
do you think it's possible we get an
hour-long episode i haven't heard
anything about it but i haven't heard
anything against it either i would just
say they need to
i i think they should honestly because
i've enjoyed the story every episode has
kind of helped regain my hype for the
next one but now we have one more and
i'm a little concerned concerned
i'm concerned
yeah i feel like even an hour is just
not gonna do it i mean you could do it
in an hour but there's definitely gonna
be some type of cliffhanger in this one
which will make it a little unique to a
lot of the disney plus series other than
loki that's gonna leave a very open
ended
like how is this connecting to the mcu
like loki's like the whole multiverse
thing i guess even one division was kind
of like the whole multiverse thing with
the book
so i don't know how this is this is
gonna have multiverse implications but
it's gonna have some type of avengers
team up young avengers dark avengers
thunderbolts implication at the end and
i think that'll be very exciting
i'm
concerned uh jeff thanks for the super
chat holy moly kingpin hired at elena
and roo valentino
well yolanda and running right i mean
yeah he like tipped him off right i i'm
wondering the back story between
clint slash hot guys ronan and kingpin
right i'm wondering because he's clearly
rant into him
so i'm like once that's another thing
they're gonna have to really kind of
explain that's gonna be the first thing
that happens next episode they're going
to be sitting at the table
and clint is going to be like yeah this
is who this is this is what he's done
this is you know blah blah blah blah
that's going to be
yeah
yeah yeah yeah well there's a lot
but i have two super chats
iggy kudos thank you for that super chat
yolanda mentions the new and improved
statue of liberty is it what we've seen
in the home trailers of the connection
that's what i said like as we were going
i was like is this i think they might
mean the new one with the captain
america shield
i think that's what that has to be
referring to
oh 100
oh okay because i don't i can't remember
when this takes place but far from home
takes place what
eight months after end game i believe
six or eight months which means no way
home also takes place that because it
it's in the same time and um right it's
pretty close as well because we've seen
in the trailers the the rogers broadway
musical
right
oh gosh we're getting tired uh bradley
jones thanks for another super chat
something he just thought of val visits
yelena after eleanor's phone call on
episode four i think eleanor called
valentina
to hire yelena to kill clint yeah it
kind of looks like it
uh i think there's a connection
though no no i don't think so either i
think there's a connection between
hawkeye's wife and kingpin
because he's mentioned her hawkeye's
wife and kingpin have a connection
because hawkeye's mentioned kingpin to
her several times you know the big guy
yeah he talked about her this one so
she's he's talking to her specifically
about kingpin and she knows who it is
like i feel like there's something there
like there's some type of like
she used to work for him and he saved
her from that the watch has that
connection
kind of like with black widow
yeah what i'm thinking maybe now i'm
kind of thinking it might be like a john
wick thing where john wick would work
for a mafia and was like i want out and
then the guy was like all right you do
this and you're go you're out and he
does it right and he gets out maybe it
was kind of like
you know
he
he wants you know laura out and
kingpin's like all right hawkeye i tell
you what you do this for me i'll let her
out
and that's where he killed maya's dad
maybe and he got her out right so some
type of connecting piece like that that
will really tie the whole thing in a
nice pretty bow christmas pun intended
and um
i think that's probably our best bet i
always get the bomb did you get a point
10
that no it was not that funny puns puns
do not get 10 points woman
i didn't even laugh i smiled
you left like a good five seconds after
[Laughter]
but um yeah i think that's probably our
best bet for what to expect is gonna be
some type of connection for the wife to
kingpin clint had to clean up the mess
now he's trying to cover their tracks
and it's all kind of going all over the
place and the watch somehow proves the
implication of her being involved with
kingpin and
yeah
uh el yaki
won thanks for super chat i want to see
kate and jack tell in order to take a
hike and build a new father-daughter
mental relationship dude i'm like
feeling for my boy jack
or jack he got done wrong
troy james think of super chat do you
think it was clint as ronin killing
ecostate or possibly cause he dressed up
as ronin that's what i've been thinking
i i
i was thinking that it was
somebody else not actually him
but hawkeye did say you know that night
no i was sent there
you know
your boss wanted him dead right so
we'll see
it's fire it's fire it's fire
thanks for super chat what if the watch
has something hidden about daredevil
which why kingpin wants to take it
wren's maybe hawk and devil worked
together that's a theory i had actually
that i talked about in my last breakdown
i think yeah maybe it does and maybe you
know he wants it to reveal
daredevil's identity
you know trying to figure that out um
i i think yeah i think maybe
i think maybe but we'll see
king j thanks for super chat i think
charlie cox might quit cameo i mean i
hope but at this point there's a lot in
it
they might mention him
maybe hawkeye's like yeah i worked with
this guy but you know what i mean like
so i don't
know
[Music]
yes uh kingpin is definitely confirmed
uh-huh kingpin and it's dinosaur as well
so
for sure
well next week is gonna be
it's gonna be a big one where's my
calendar
well the next week needs to be i mean
next week's freaking christmas twenty
twenty first twenty second i'm gonna be
home in orlando the watch party is gonna
be rough
yep me too i'm gonna be at my mom's
place um
i'm gonna be at your mom
so
yeah
but wow
ali with the silent one wait a second oh
no last week's in that last episode okay
yeah what you're okay hold on hold on
you're not gonna
the last episode is the same week as
christmas they're not gonna kill hawkeye
the same week as christmas you can't
kill you can't do that
they're not gonna kill hawkeye in the
same way
they're not gonna do that to us there's
no way if they kill hawkeye i'm
returning all the christmas presents i
bought from disney to back back to the
so
so
so i hear some people i see some people
saying like
oh man like the finale of this this show
is gonna be a letdown like the other
ones i actually think this one has kind
of potential potential i i really do i
think like a whole bunch of crap
can go down like so much stuff can go
down and like
i mean kingpin is is huge
physically and
in the
and what you know the implications of
him are like huge
and and there's so much to wrap up
literally
i'm here for the isn't she trying her
hardest
i have a question for you in a second
but wait um and then and then
i just think there's so much that could
happen especially if we
you know what
that
what if elena isn't part of a new
dark avengers or thunderbolts at all
because in the beginning of this episode
that girl ann was telling her
um
you know you can work for hire and
contract and blah blah blah blah and
make a lot of money
so
val is some government person
and the government hires independent
contractors to do stuff like that
happens in real life
so
maybe elena's just a black widow who's
for hire and
works for whoever to do whatever and val
specifically call maybe she's not really
part of a bigger group maybe she was
just hired
now
i just wonder why the government would
hire her to kill
oh do we have to quit
i don't have any doubts that about that
at all
i'm just trying to see like i'm just
trying to make it make sense that's all
and i and i think we have the advantage
now of having had so many
um
disney plus shows that we know at the
end the majority of the information is
going to tie back into hawkeye
oh for sure
that's just how these theories kind of
work like even if we get some kind of
lead of what's gonna happen with the
young avengers or you know with kingpin
and the future of echo and all that like
it's gonna be about hawkeye the finale's
gonna revolve around him and his family
and there's gonna be some type of
closure for the character and and that's
the end of it so it's gonna make that
kind of sense and it's gonna be a lot of
fun whatever it is i think hawkeye's
gonna get his swan song and we're gonna
move on i don't think they're gonna kill
him two days before christmas
no they're not gonna kill him they're
definitely not gonna kill him um
i think to
right here
um super chat thank you moo moo machines
how do you think clint will persuade you
linda so what i'm thinking is going to
happen
you know they're going to have a talk i
think i think kate kind of already got
yelena on the whole hawkeye might be
good type of thing you know um and i
think hawkeye's just going to tell her
what happened and be like if you want to
kill me kill me i've killed many people
whatever blah blah blah blah but i loved
your sister and i wanted it to be me
right
i blah blah blah blah so
that'll be easy recompense i think
right i kind of do have a question
though like
hawkeye was like nat forgive me for what
i'm about to do what what he didn't
really do anything
what did he do
i don't know i feel like they were just
trying to show us that memorial
yeah i mean
i and i thought we were going to see the
avengers tower
i was because it's right there under
that bridge
maybe that maybe it's the building right
i was hoping we were going to see it but
maybe that's the building who knows
um haiti thanks for the super chat do
you think elena will forgive clint for
letting natasha jump also what if she
ends up being kate's black widow
if she ends up being kate's black widow
i'm not sure i understand that question
but
um
oh i get it like
kate becomes hawkeye yolanda becomes
black widow and that's the duo that'd be
pretty cool that'd be that yeah that'd
be pretty cool um i think elena will yes
i think because i think clint will be
like yeah i want it to be me i tried but
your sister's so freaking stubborn
it happened right i mean you know like i
mean
he's gonna say i hit her you know we
fought and i tried to join blah blah
blah blah
yeah i know it's gonna be it's gonna be
it's gonna clean up nicely i think
sometimes we worry and i like we use the
word concerned about maybe the end of
the series but marvel never really lets
us down like they always manage to make
it work i'm just concerned that they're
gonna
leave us with some cliffhangers for the
echo series well yeah that's gonna be
rough because that's just kind of like
come on i don't wanna wait
[Music]
yeah but then we're gonna have to wait
like a year for it to happen i know yeah
and it gives us something to look
forward to there's plenty to look
forward to there is enough to look
forward to you know knight
freaking doctor strange guardians three
thor
thunder there's so much
you know what my favorite part of this
stream has been
what me smiling in the back all the
people all of the people coming in
on my chat and on yours because i'm
reading yours as well spiderman
pretending like they know and throwing
out fake spoilers yeah that's what i've
been trying to tell everybody i'm like
guys people are throwing big spoilers in
here like
i'm i'm reading them these aren't like
real it's not even close to right
everyone's like stop the chat they're
posting spoilers it's like if i if i
really thought like first of all even if
you're posting a spoiler i promise you
you're just probably guessing because
anybody who was at the premiere last
night it's not gonna say i'm not gonna
say anything
and even if like i didn't like you know
tell sony i won't say anything i still
wouldn't say anything because i want to
want to spoil it if you saw the movie
you wouldn't want it spoiled for you
would yes it was such an experience yeah
so
i mean
literally we're seeing it this week guys
yeah i mean but people are posting fake
spoilers or right people coming into
chats acting like they know stuff and
they're just like oh this is it i know
it's like yeah you don't know
um
cornet
zero cornetto thank you for that super
chat
um
i don't think clint's gonna die
um
i kind of don't think yelena is part of
some bigger organization i think she was
just an assassin for hire and that's how
she makes money after being released
from the
uh black widow
what the heck's his name i can't
remember his name the bad guy
i don't remember
oh it's wendy
yeah oh um john atkins bringing a good
point i think becoming ronin again is
why he apologized to nat he put on the
suit
uh it was a struggle she saved him from
all that that would make the most sense
makes sense that's a good point john
thank you so much for saying that thanks
john that makes sense
thanks john dracoff that's his name i
remembered great cough derek look dad
drake loves daughter yeah um
allie what did you think about yolena
we had uh we had a lot of time to talk
to her do you say she's hot
she's hilarious
uh but what did you think i feel like
you know we got a long time to talk to
her we got a long time to hear how she's
gonna settle in the mcu and i think this
is the tone we can see in the future for
so
she's very confident in herself
and
that's an understatement
she i don't know she just this
the little bit that we had today of her
was a lot in just a little bit and she
was just very confident and
funny
she's hilarious
so
good i'm excited to see her in the
future she's pretty great she was pretty
good in black widow too yeah i liked how
long they put her in because it was kind
of fun to listen to her just be she was
funny not yeah that was a good scene
but actually just sit there and talk
i'm not going to kill you you'd already
be dead
i wouldn't have ever had a chance to
close the door absolutely not
jim yeah jim x mafia thanks for the
super chat it's king fin mephista next
week totally thanks warren and chris
thank you
and uh hey thank you
and thank you larry
vales
vals
sorry if i didn't pronounce all right
but thank you
it was a fun video to do
the young avengers seem really old to me
i mean yeah kids they're not they're not
kids yeah but we'll see i mean we got
miss marvel
um
stature coming up and quantomania
the twins you know
we'll see
that's true
yeah poor jack
jack i knew he was gonna take the fall
i've never worked a day in my life i've
never worked a day in my life
love it fair point i mean i was like
yeah i think i'm richer than anybody
here yeah
jeez
he was so calm
yeah don't worry i'll be back for your
apartment which means he is innocent
because he is like dude literally like
he's calm because he's like yeah no this
literally isn't me how many lawyers i
have right like for sure definitely not
me like i did like if i didn't do
anything i'd be like what the no i like
i def i promise you it wasn't me i'd be
like all right do whatever you got to do
but i'm getting out of here because i
didn't do it like
so
we'll see
absolutely
well
well
this is a good episode movement machine
thanks for another super chat
saw no way home this morning because it
released earlier in korea ooh
being a decent person i suppose but
people should know this movie
and two post credits is hype yes
yes
for not posting any spoilers
oh yeah
all right well this was fun
always fun we got in today from la so
we're super tired
uh and chris
and ally cat are leaving tomorrow so
for christmas parties
she exposed he exposed his identity as
ronan and she wanted him to live a
normal life
that's what clint did i think yes thanks
cornetto i i agree with that yeah i he
went back as ronan in which you learn
sorry well i'm mixing up the black
widows natasha pulled him out of that
so
for sure but uh let's uh let's start
stop with the super chats please i don't
want to miss any
um
because
we're going about to get off right here
so
hey larry thank you yeah the reaction
was we were like wow like yeah
i was telling them like we actually sat
there for a second after we started
working
and i'm still wrapping my head around i
can't wait to see it again just because
it's so awesome you're all gonna love
spiderman new way home i can't wait for
you guys to see it
i can't wait to see you
yeah so
okay well next week is
big a lot coming next week
a lot coming next week so be sure to be
back here next week we'll be talking
about it we'll be watching it and
wow i just
drop all your theories in the comments
just drop them all
some theories dropped
back
all the [ __ ] theories
[Laughter]
so all right well thank you all for
joining thank you to everybody who
watched thank you everybody who chatted
thank you to everybody who super chatted
and of course thank you to my members
memberships are now live on the channel
join the cosmic fam if you want
it supports the channel and helps us
produce better videos that's what it's
for so thank you thank you thank you to
everybody who became a member today um
don't forget to check out marvel minute
news which is allie's channel cosmic
culture which is chris's channel go go
go
i think we are dubbed now the cosmic
crew i think yeah
[Applause]
cosmic
[Music]
we'll have to get cosmic crew pizza
shirts
so but all right everybody said you guys
are extremely dedicated for your hard
work and i appreciate everything you've
done this year thank you
yeah
um
all right go get sleep everybody go get
sleep because that's what i'm about to
do i'm about to pass out look out for my
breakdown tomorrow it's going to come at
a later time and click on it quite
honestly
there's only like a few things to break
down and it wasn't it should be a pretty
straightforward breakdown because it was
a pretty straightforward episode
yeah in all honesty it was like yolina's
straight up was like
yo i've been hired we saw the
post-credits scene and then we find out
that it was eleanor that hired her and
then kingpin and besides that i mean
everything else is pretty
straightforward the only thing that we
really still are
wondering about is the watch and
hawkeye's wife
and i think we may have figured out a
pretty good theory for that i i think
she's mockingbird or someone else that
maybe worked out worked for kingpin but
we'll see next week
is it's when it all happens so we'll see
you here next week love you subscribe to
marvel minute news
all the links have been in the chat guys
subscribe to these other two channels
be sure to do it
love you all thank you for being here
whether you're just watching commenting
super chatting joining the membership
love you all and we'll see you
we're doing this we're doing this is
this our thing now yeah i guess i don't
know
i don't know
um
thank you mr anderson for being an
awesome awesome mod
finger hearts for mr anderson and you
all uh
we love you and before this gets really
weird we're gonna
you all see you next time woof woof bye
guys you don't get to talk anymore
i'm just kidding
same for me here all of you guys sitting
here participating ali and warren just
being so cute over here my um awesome
it's just a blast uh we were very tired
we flew in today but we couldn't have
not streamed because we love to
just chat with you guys and and so many
people supporting the channel supporting
us we got so much love over the last few
days on
youtube and twitter it felt really good
so thank you everybody i getting bark
barks and woof woofs over here online
goodbye everybody we love you
good night guys